el Primer Ministro Richie es una lideró
en Irlanda del Norte reuniones con los
diferentes partidos políticos pero
Especialmente con los unionistas del
partido d up para lograr el consenso y
el apoyo político para lo que será el
nuevo acuerdo entre Londres y Bruselas
sobre el protocolo de Irlanda del Norte
que creó una nueva frontera comercial en
el mar de Irlanda y que mantenía
enfrentados a los dos lados del Canal de
la Mancha y que tantos inconvenientes
había creado para la población en
Irlanda del Norte esta figura jurídica
que se creó tras el acuerdo brexit
mantenía a Irlanda del Norte que hace
parte del Reino Unido dentro del sistema
de aduanas y económico de la Unión
Europea lo que hacía que por ejemplo el
envío de cualquier mercancía de una
ciudad británica como Londres por
ejemplo a Irlanda del Norte A belfast el
mismo país casi que fuera un trámite de
exportación el jefe del partido
unionista tras esta reunión con Richie
sunak Jeffrey donaldson dijo que había
habido progreso Pero que todavía falta
trabajo y también los republicanos del
chinfeng coincidieron en que en que
había un progreso importante Lo cierto
es que Richie sunak estará en la
conferencia de seguridad en Múnich donde
se reunirá con otros líderes europeos
para tratar de sellar ese nuevo acuerdo
sobre el protocolo de Irlanda del Norte
bien importante para que se pueda
restablecer el poder político en esa
región británica